leute ihr kennt ja dass hier eine ganz
normale images jeder hat sich auf seinem
handy jeder kann sie benutzen und alle
paar monate kommen neue images zu den
bisherigen coaches dazu da ist neue
dinge gibt die die community fordert da
es neue ereignisse gibt und auch einfach
noch nicht alles das es irgendwo auf der
welt gibt als erotisch abgedeckt wurde
und vor einer woche kam dann das große
namen von wegen handy 2009/10 ams sind
jetzt festgelegt worden first call to
handle study neurology 2009 team schauen
wir uns heute mal zusammen ancelotti pda
präsentiert alle 230 9
es gab noch keinen genen smiley mio es
gab einen schlafenden smiley aber noch
keinen der ghent den finde ich
tatsächlich sehr sinnvoll dass er da
zugefügt wie
so groß ist deine scheiße soll der
aussagen hätte das ist so eine pin
schinken was heißt überhaupt hinsching
heißt kneifen ja doch okay das ist schon
so kneifen also den smiley verstehe ich
nicht so ganz dass ich weiß wann man den
senden würde den alten kumpel von einem
sagte haye und dass man morgen treffen
und man selbst sagte ja ok klar lass uns
treffen und dann am nächsten tag
schreibt dass er haye ich kann nicht
meine freundin mit mir spazieren gehen
wie heißt du nen kleinjohann also bisher
finde ich bei dem es wirklich cool auch
okay den gibt es natürlich auch noch
einen anderen farben bin ich eigentlich
der einzige der findet dass das ziemlich
unnötig ist dass es in jeder farbe gibt
also klar natürlich sagt man jetzt haye
aber es gibt ja auch verschiedene
hautfarben blabla aber ich meine die
standard im auto warten jahrelang alle
gelb keiner hat eine gelbe haut damit
hat man nichts falsch gemacht ich finde
die gelben die models hätten absolut
ausgereicht haben hier
es gibt es gibt noch
die hände halten oder hier natürlich
klar da sind die beiden männer die
zusammen hände halten aber
wahrscheinlich geht es hier um
ach so das sind
das versteht
gender inklusive mix kind so bisher gibt
es sie nur in gelb und hier kommen jetzt
noch in der dunkleren hautfarbe der
helleren hautfarbe hinzu also finde ich
auch interessant wie es in die richtung
halt weitergeht und wie jetzt sogar so
imagine hersteller also ja hier auch
nochmal weiblichen natürlich jetzt auch
energy hersteller beziehungsweise die
produzenten davon hier auch nochmal die
männer die wir eigentlich schon hatten
aber jetzt geht es natürlich alles durch
empfindlich sehr interessant wie auch
die sich sage ich mal den geschehnissen
anpassen hat sich eigentlich jemals
jemand beschwert dass es keine images in
anderen farben gibt es wäre
wahrscheinlich auch noch mal interessant
zu wissen aber finde ich auf jeden fall
cool dass das auch eingefügt wird was
mich auch allgemein war interessieren
würde ist was wünscht ihr euch für ein
motto wenn ihr einen wunsch frei hätten
schreibt immer gerne und in die
kommentare was würdet ihr hinzufügen
standing person women men also
ach so ein mann eine frau und gender und
spezifische personen hier gibt es auch
noch mal alles drei also mann frau und
gender unspezifischen hier endlich alter
also ich wollte ihn jetzt nicht wirklich
direkt nutzen den rollstuhl im auge ich
habe mich schon mal gefragt warum gibt
es denn eigentlich nicht allgemeinheit
so die tatsache dass es sechs
verschiedene taschen images gibt aber
keinen rollstuhl oder auch einfach 16
verschiedene katzen images so wenig ne
katze heult oder herzen den augen hat
aber dafür gibt es nur einen hund der
kann einfach nicht seine gefühle zeigen
und es gibt doch nur ein scheißhaufen so
hey was ist mit durchfall oder was ist
wenn die familie mehr als zwei kinder
haben will
fragen über fragen der als nächstes
haben wir dann natürlich women und men
in einem rollstuhl
die sache ist da allerdings wieder was
ist mit dem mit dieser person bin ich
wirklich sehr sehr interessant das ist
jetzt mann frau und gender neutral oder
wie das heißt gibt ich möchte überhaupt
nicht diskriminierend wirken oder
rassistisch oder sonst irgendwas ich
glaube ihr müsstet mich kennen dass ich
nicht so aber man muss ja wirklich in
der heutigen zeit in der wir leben sehr
sehr sehr sehr doll aufpassen was man
sagt und ich bin ganz ehrlich ich kann
es nicht verstehen wie der jetzt so ein
großer hektik drum gemacht wird weil was
genau heißt gender neutral ich will mich
jetzt um gottes willen keine debatte
lostreten aber das was ich meine
aber ich meine leute um e mails gehen
allerdings ist das natürlich wirklich
interessant dass hier dann keine
personen auf alles ist
ach das ist ein blindenstock
okay das ist wirklich ein interessantes
update bei den letzten updates kam halt
immer so sachen dazu wie hey wir haben
jetzt jedoch ein drachen hinzugefügt und
noch zwei drei tiere aber diesmal gehts
wirklich so darum hey wir schauen uns
die entwicklung der gesellschaft an und
machen einen blindenstock bin ich auch
interessant hier auch wieder mann und
hummel mit blindenstock eine normale
person ein hörgerät also irgendwie
übertreiben sie es aber auch so ein
bisschen wenn das updaten namen hätte
dann was es auch die person was heißt
dies schwerhörig ich dachte erst das
wäre so na na na das macht man aber
nicht aber als es geht tatsächlich um
schwerhörig kalt und damit kann man dann
jemanden schicken hey bist du ist
schwerhörig hast du nicht zugehört ist's
her war keine maut dabei wo ich mir
wirklich gesagt hat haye den vermisse
ich im täglichen gebrauch aber wir haben
ja noch ein paar leute sind jetzt monate
sorina überhaupt
dominierend ich finde
richtig richtig geil dass es solche
möglichkeiten gibt mit einem
mechanischen arm oder einem mechanischen
beinen aber das als images einzuführen
also ich glaube auch niemand der jetzt
irgendwie mechanischen arm hat er sagt
jetzt haye endlich habe ich so versteht
ihr was ich meine dass das finde ich ein
bisschen übertrieben aber ich finde auf
jeden fall interessant dass sich der im
audi hier bewegt
service dogs das ist cool das finde ich
das habe ich noch gar nicht nachgedacht
es gibt endlich einen flamingo meine
damen oder herren spaßig war vor einem
jahr mit jule im zoo und hab da noch
eine story gemacht die habe ich aber
leider nicht mehr
ich habe doch gesagt hey wir sind
familie und ich würde es gerne machen
aber es gibt einfach keinen nun kommt
der flamingos miley also im neuen update
demnächst ein stinktier und eine
ausdauer und auch noch ein
das nice alter endlich gibt es ein vde
mode ikone wie sehr einfach ist das wird
hundertprozentig mein neuer status
überall seien einfach 7000 fr
aber wir merken schon wir sind bei den
tieren angelangt und jetzt sind wir bei
zwiebeln weiter es gab keine zwiebel und
kein knoblauch ne kraft fünf images für
fleisch aber keine zwiebeln knoblauch
aber weiter geht's freude wir sind erst
bei der hälfte von den 230 energies eine
waffel und butter dass es tatsächlich
was was ich auch bisher nie gesehen habe
verlassen
mate drink alter what the [ __ ] also wir
sind jetzt hier beim essen angelangt als
nächstes haben wir hier beverage box und
eis
stimmt
einfach
eiswürfel der emo die sieht halt auch
mega geil aus mal schauen was die
nächste kategorie ist die uns hier
vorgestellt wird
es gibt neue badehosen und badeanzüge
das finde ich auf jeden fall auch cool
auch ein
es gibt jetzt auch unterhosen
sicherheitsweste finde ich auch sehr
cool
sari ja wenn ich jetzt nicht nutzen
weiter geht's mit der nächsten kategorie
es gibt nun ein braunes hemd und ein
weißes herz weißes herz garstedt weißes
hemd und ein blaues quadrat das
natürlich auch wichtig habe ein weißes
herz gab es noch nicht und das finde ich
sehr sehr cool es gibt auch noch andere
square andere kreise gibt es auch noch
also sind jetzt bei den formen
angekommen place ist ein transport es
gibt sie nun eine rikscha ein hotel ist
gibt den saturn das ist sehr gut
keine ahnung wann man einen saturn
energie nutzt als nächstes haben wir
dann hier ballettschuhe und einen
fallschirm finde ich auf jeden fall auch
interessant eine axt gab es bisher noch
nicht okay krassem es gibt noch pflaster
ein
blutstropfen also ich meine ja es macht
sinn finde ich auch cool in den dings
aber ein blutstropfen
also ich frag mich ist da bedarf also
würde tieren blutstropfen mode überhaupt
nutzen könnt ihr mal gern schreiben gab
es ja schon schwer oder heavy cross soll
viele morde die sind ja vorgestellt
werden da denkt man sich so gibt es ja
eigentlich noch nicht eine die allem
weil sie gar nicht was das ist
bungies folgende instrumente und razer
das ist zum schneiden stethoskop und ein
drachen gibt es auch noch und ein jojo
menschen heutzutage also ein jojo wird
auch noch hinzugefügt das finde ich sehr
interessant
das waren tatsächlich alle 230 images
für 2009/10 das ist das logo von dem
multimedia und das war's ja eigentlich
gar nicht mal so geil dass updates was
wird hier empfohlen lobster images tumor
lex following public outcry europa im
musikbiz zwei beiden märkten
aber gut wie können wir das update jetzt
mal zusammenfassen ein alpaka energy
gibt es noch immer nicht von daher
kriegt das video erst mal in fetten
daumen runter
na gut die können eigentlich gar nichts
führt ich weiß nicht was haltet ihr von
dem neuen images die demnächst in einem
neuen update auf alle geräte kommen
sollen also nicht nur auf apple iphone
sondern auch auf huawei und samsung und
google phone und keine ahnung vielleicht
auch auf euer altes drecks nokia mit der
kurbel dran robert was hältst du davon
sollen mal einen beschissenen strauß ihm
richie hinzufügen stimmt es gibt auch
einfach noch immer keinen strauss also
die sache die ich mir gewünscht hätte
wär halt strauß energy einpacker
emotionen mehr pizzen es gibt nur einen
verdammten pizza smiley also ich weiß
nicht was ich von diesem update halten
soll
ich dachte einfach nur hey ich nutze
immer images oft den titeln oft in
videos ganz ganz häufig in meinen
stories auf instagram et cetera deswegen
hey ihr kennt die neuen images die
kommen demnächst mit einem update auf
euer handy was haltet ihr davon schreibt
es mir gerne in die kommentare das
leichter wenn euch das video hier
gefallen hat und wir sehen uns wieder
sobald es ein alpaka eben heute gibt
[Musik]